And the big announcement this week,
Wednesday, my babies,
my special drops on Netflix. April 14th,
no pain. That's the title, no pain. Netflix,
April 14th, your boys got another special.
[Inaudible].
Here. It comes. Get it in your queue. What you can do is you can go on,
you know what to, if you're a true baby,
if you're a real down and sucking baby,
you know, go to Netflix right now, you go to Netflix,
you pull it up on your app. You go to search you type in no pain.
That's the first thing that comes up crystally and no pain. Click on that.
And then you go remind me right there we go.
Just clicked on it, turned into a checkmark, go do that now.
And watch it on April 14th. Now I'm going to do, what is April 14th? Is that,
uh, well, I don't know what day that is, but I'm gonna,
I want you guys all to watch it that day. It's going to come out, you know,
and we're all gonna, you know, I can tell you,
I'm going to go crazy on Twitter babies. I'm going to tweet you back that day.
And, uh, it's a Tuesday, so I'll drop the podcast on that day. Maybe man,
I'll drop the podcast the day before. I'll remind you that the coming.
Uh, but no pain, April 14th, Netflix. And I will say
I I've seen it. I did it. I was there when I shot it.
Obviously it was me. It's the best special I've done. Uh,
it's the best taping I've had. Um,
I did white male black comic in on, uh, in, um,
for comedy central. To me that always has a special place in my heart.
That was my first one. All the decks. The deck was stacked. I had the,
I was this young gun coming up. I was ready to do a special,
I had this idea where I know what's funny. I got this.
This is what's funny to me. And I, I felt really good about it.
That was a great special, I think for me,
I'm not saying whether or not it was great,
but I'm saying for me was a great special, I'm not trying to toot my own horn,
but for me, I, for me, it was, it was great.
I felt great about it. It came out great. I loved it.
I hired my dad to direct it. Kept it in the fam. It was awesome.
I was so Italian about it. I kept it in the family. Dude.
I should have called the special spaghetti and meatballs,
but instead I decided to go with white male black comic. It was so Italian.
I kept it in the family. My mom came out, my mom came out, sat in the audience.
I kept it in the family. It's like,
my last name was Dawn's polio or some, but it's still,
it's still Italian. But anyway, should've called it spaghetti and meatballs,
but I didn't. And then I did a second special incorrigible.
That was first Netflix special. Now I like this special,
but to me it was all the stuff that I still thought was funny that I didn't put
on white male, black comic. So to me, white male,
black comic was like the bang and.
And then in cordial was the stuff that was like the odds and ends.
It was like the B side of what my black comic.
And I also think that the best stuff in incorrigible was at the end.
And that was by design. Because as a comic, you put your good.
At the end of the closer, the landscape has changed since then,
because that special was about an hour and 20 minutes.
Now that's too long for a special, I didn't think about that back then,
because that was like the 20th Netflix special that they ever made.
And I realized that people were watching the shorter,
cause they don't want to invest their time, watching the best stuff.
And incorrigible is at the end.
And I know that a lot of people checked out of it because the beginning of it,
people always reference the beginning of it and that's not the good.
And I get all bummed because I'm like, ah, you didn't watch it.
People are watching 30 minutes of the special. I know that.
So man on fi so incorrigible is, is fine. I liked it,
man, on fire to me. Oh. And by the way, in cordial, the taping went great. Okay,
man, on fire to me was top loaded.
I put the bang and up front because I knew now that there was this way that
Netflix and the streaming services were doing it,
that you were watching the first part to check
it out. So I put the bang and up front the first twenty-five minutes. Dang,
dang, dang, dang. Dang. Right. Okay. And then I,
and then I end it with a nice sweet story that, you know, to me, it was very,
for me, it meant a lot in my life. At that time,
man on fire was my best material. For sure. To me,
hands down. Now there were technical difficulties shooting, the special,
the mic cutout. I had to redo some stuff. The audience was,
it sounds good in the, in the, in the special,
but the audience was okay. So I was really trying to bring it,
but not too hard for the audience because you never want to bring it too hard
for the level of the audience. You want to, some,
you want to kind of meet the audience halfway.
Sometimes the energy comes in and it's not popping and it's not unimportant and
you gotta make it on and popping.
But you can't go in with this unimportant energy right off the bat.
If the inner, if the, if the audience is not there, so you gotta take it,
you gotta meet the audience. You gotta go like this. Hello audience,
shake hands with who the audience is. Come on into my study.
Let's read a little bit about what's going on and then let's go into the
kitchen. Oh, the food's good though. Isn't it? Yeah. Well,
why don't you come into the and sucking room? Oh, you didn't know. We had that,
but now it's unemployment.
You got to start with the foil and then you got to take them in to the study.
You got to show them your book collection. Huh? Very nice. Okay, cool.
This is the audience. Oh, okay. Very cool. Oh, I like this.
I've read that before you take them into the kitchen.
You give him a little bit of hors d'oeuvres and they're like, wow,
this is very tasty. Wow. Okay. Very cool. That's cool.
You show me your study and while the foil wasn't pressing,
it was it wasn't precedent. Now all of a sudden here's the and sucking room.
That's what you're always trying to get to in a special is the and sucking room.
But the audience is not always there for and sucking. You got to convince them,
Oh, you're here for the and sucking orange yet.
Sometimes there's 50 year old Mormons in your audience. Oh,
I don't know about that. Well, let me convince you about the and sucking room.
Okay.
So what happens is the whole time my man on fire,
I was trying to convince this audience to come with me to the and sucking room.
And a lot of people were on board,
but some of them were just there for a jolly good time, whatever. That's fine,
dude. They want it to hang out in the foyer and mingle and have an order.
And that's fine too, because you could have a good time nor d'oeuvres,
but that's like that conversational. That's like, that was like, Oh wow.
Last night was really fun.
But was it fun or did you really just kick it and learn some stuff?
Did you really just have great conversation? Reacting like an adult now?
You know me, that's not my vibe. I don't sit there and act like an adult.
Not all night long. I'm done for and sucking.
So I'm going to be in the second room.
You guys hang out with the hors d'oeuvres,
that's what it was like for manna fire, but it was my best material.
And you can't tell when you're watching the special. So that's that.
So white male black comic up until no pain, white belt.
Let me say I'm leaving no pain out of this. White, my black comic best special.
All the cards fell where they may, all the deck was stacked.
I should say the stars fell and aligned. Okay.
Incorrigible, great taping. But the odds and ends of Blackwell, blackmail,
white comic, this stuff I left out. So then I was like, okay,
w ma man on fire, best, best material.
However audience they were in order of audience.
Some of them were there for and sucking, but your boy wasn't going to drag him.
So we had a nice conversation, no pain.
I decided I'm going to go for broke best material to me,
best material I've done. Now, this is the whole deal. You get you, you,
you grow for me. Best material, the audience,
bro, the audience.
It was like they just came in in shorts.
They were down for sucking and right away. The audience,
the first audience I shot great. Walked off the stage.
My agent goes like this. Well, we don't even need to, we don't need to.
We need to, uh, do the second taping. The second taping.
First five minutes in, I was like, Oh man, this is the taping.
We don't even need that first audience.
So the first audience came from and sucking. The second audience came.
I mean, you know, whatever's on the top of higher than in second.
But my point is the material, the audience. And guess what, dude,
I fired my dad from shooting it. I fired him. He's my dad.
And I fired him. I fired him. I took him. I hired him on the second,
on the first episode, thanking him for my whole childhood con. Congratulations.
You're welcome. I've given you a job. Sure. I only gave you $7,000 to do it,
but this makes up for everything you've done.
The second one as if that wasn't enough,
hired him again for $7,000. Now that's $14,000.
I've given my dad now. I haven't given it to him, but Netflix did now,
whatever your welcome. The third special, Hey dad,
here's another $7,000. You're welcome. Times three.
And then your boy wanted to make a change.
So what he did was I looked at my dad. I said, Hey, dad, you're fired.
And then he said, what? And I said, Hey, Matt, you want to do my next special?
And my dad said this the best firing ever,
and my brother came through and took a Gatling gun. And just
[inaudible]. It was great dude. The best dude. And it looks the.
It looks so good. This is the best special I've ever done.
And if you don't think so, what am I going to do, dude?
What am I going to do? This is no pain.
What am I going to do?
It's basically what I did on the follow, the leader tour.
I didn't want to call it.
Follow the leader because your boy doesn't usually call specials the tornadoes,
but it's called no pain, man. This is cool. The background is purple. What?
The background? It's purple.
First one was blue. Second one. First one was first. One was first one.
It was an industrial vibe. Blue. Second one was rockstar blue.
Third one was red. And then your boy goes purple.
What is a Prince?
Anyway, dude,
I can't wait for this thing to come out and just for just that's it every
special I do. I'm like, all right, maybe I'll maybe that's it now.
What am I going to do? And I don't think I'll be able to do it again.
Some of the I do is funny. Some of it's not, you know, whatever killed it,
deal with it. That,
that sunglasses mean where the sunglasses come down on your eyes and it goes
deal with it. That's me, bro.
Okay.
Look at this meme. The one with Morpheus. What if I told you deal with it?
Trying to put a square peg into a round hole. Um, anyway,
dude, I can't wait for this thing to come out, put it in your queue,
go right now, do it on your phone and put it on your list.
You watch a the day it drops like a true baby. Anyway, dude,
I'm being honestly annoying as right now, but this is it.
This is what I did. And I'm sorry, but I'm not dude. Everybody's two people.
That's why I love this. That's why I love Tupac, man. Everybody's two people.
That's why I love Tupac because he would make a song called Brenda's got a baby
and then he would make a song called wonder why they call you a?
And people will be like, what the? How could you do that? That's hypocritical.
And he would be like, everybody's two people. And I would be like, we may me.
You know what I mean? Everyone is kind of two people, right?
Cause sometimes you want to do in second,
but also sometimes you want to raise children.
Can't do both of those at the same time.
I mean can with one person in the race children.
Anyway.
Anyway, dude, we're having a good time, dude. We're having a really good time.
We're having a really good time. Cause I told you we are,
I can't wait for it to come out. That's a whole commercial dude.
Watch my special called no pain on a, on Netflix. Um,
and it, it just sometimes all the stars align and you get a good taping.
That's what it is. But sometimes they don't most of the time they don't. I mean,
I did the comedians of the world. That audience was man. It was like,
they were just eating breakfast. Yeah, bro.
I want to do a special with no audience one of these days and just,
just talk, man. That's kind of what, this is honestly this podcast, but
anyway, look it up. Add it to your queue.